la maison de l'étudiant c'est un cadeau
de la région ile-de-france à
l'université paris sud ils voulaient un
lieu où les étudiants puissent avoir
diverses activités associatives des
spectacles des des moments de vie des
studios d'enregistrement exter où nous
l'idée c'était un peu de continuer la
forêt de décomposer les formes en les
transformant formes géométriques et de
faire donc un bâtiment qui était
entièrement en bois mais qui est comme
une forêt qui se transforme en un objet
de science un objet de restitution un
objet informatique
on à dire le point le plus important de
la maison des étudiants ça sera la
cafétaria et on l'a agrandi démesurément
elle devait faire 30 mètres carrés est
ce que vous voyez derrière moi ici ça on
fait 300
ou est géré dans le bâtiment pour que ya
une optimisation de la lumière naturelle
bien sûr ce bâtiment est un bâtiment
extrêmement écologique c'est un bâtiment
à basse consommation
qui l'a été par choix bien avant que les
normes l'imposent il ya tout plein de
choses tout plein d'activités qui sont
possibles dans un bâtiment la grande
salle c'est la salle polyvalente une
salle de spectacles professionnels elle
est elle même connectée à toute une zone
de studio d'enregistrement qui seront à
la disposition des étudiants
il ya des zones qui sont dédiés aux jeux
aux jeux de société aux jeux vidéo il ya
des salles multifonctions qui servent à
tout le monde les réunions les exposer
etc il ya des petits bureaux pour les
différentes associations toutes ces
sales cons se convergent ici vers cette
cafétéria où il ya toutes les activités
et qui elle-même s'ouvre vers
l'extérieur
à 50 mètres d'ici il ya chez yvette qui
a toujours été un haut lieu culturel de
la culture rock et du rap de la musique
dans la vallée de cheveux qu'on aimerait
que ici se passe d'autres choses qui
répondent en fait à la maison de
l'étudiant qui est un dialogue entre les
deux qui s'instaure des échanges de avec
des activités variées et différentes
bon